welcome back the u.s marshals are asking
for your help to track down a fugitive
in this vegas fugitive report the
i-team's vanessa murphy tells us who he
is what he's wanted for
arthur wilson is a convicted bank robber
court records reveal he robbed two banks
in colorado in 2015 three days apart he
received a 41-month prison sentence
followed by a three-year supervised
release but in august according to the
u.s marshals service wilson violated
terms of that release and disappeared
now there's an active search for him mr
wilson knows he's being searched for so
we understand he's going to be a little
more difficult to find he's going to
change his patterns the deputy u.s
marshal asked not to be identified due
to the nature of his work he says his
team received information wilson is
currently in southern nevada near the
las vegas strip we have a little bit
more urgency with mr wilson due to the
nature of the offenses he points to a
criminal history in at least two states
colorado and idaho he says wilson has
arrests for four robberies on his record
along with drug charges the u.s marshals
are asking for any tips from the public
to help locate him but they also have a
warning due to what they call a
dangerous past we would caution anyone
to make in contact with mr wilson
vanessa murphy 8 news now wilson is 5 11
estimated to be 190 pounds and according
to the u.s marshals has multiple tattoos
covering his arms and chest if you have
any information on his whereabouts you
are urged to call the u.s marshals at
725-270